Let us speak of our nation's monuments. When you're at the Statue of Liberty or standing under the Rotunda at the US Capitol, when you're at the Alamo, it is clear what they mean. But why do thousands of tourists go every day of the summer to Four Corners, that spot in the wilderness where Utah, Arizona, New Mexico, and Colorado-- four different states-- meet at one point.
让我们谈谈我们国家的纪念碑。当你站在自由女神像前，或者站在美国国会大厦的圆形大厅下，当你站在阿拉莫时，它们的意义显而易见。但为什么每天夏天都有成千上万的游客前往四角落（Four Corners），那个位于犹他州、亚利桑那州、新墨西哥州和科罗拉多州——四个不同州——交汇于一点的荒野之地呢？
I went this summer, drawn inexorably, magnetically, without quite knowing why, just like every other wandering tourist who strays within 250 miles of the place. Chances are, you have done this yourself. You've driven three or four hours out of your way. And you show up. And there's a marker on the ground, ringed by dozens, literally dozens, of t-shirt stands. And families come. And they stand on the supposed spot where the four states meet. And what? They hold hands, they sit on the ground. And then mom or dad or sis stands on a little platform they have there, built specially for this purpose, and takes a snapshot.
今年夏天我也去了，不可抗拒地、像被磁铁吸引了一样，甚至没完全明白为什么，就像每一个游荡到该地点250英里范围内的游客一样。你很有可能自己也做过这种事。你绕路开了三四个小时的车。然后你到了。地上有一个标志，被几十个、确实是几十个T恤摊位环绕着。家庭游客们来了。他们站在四个州交汇的所谓地点上。然后呢？他们手拉手，坐在地上。然后妈妈、爸爸或姐妹站在那里专门为此建造的小平台上，拍一张快照。
And then, often, there's this kind of aftermath moment where everybody sort of stands around haplessly like, what was that all about? We came for this? And then the next group comes in. The arbitrariness of it all, I think, is lost on no one. I saw one family with young kids who simply placed a teddy bear on the spot where the four states meet, and snapped a picture of that.
之后，通常会有一种后续时刻，每个人都无所适从地站在那里，好像在想：刚才那是怎么回事？我们就是为了这个来的？然后下一组游客又来了。我认为，这其中的随意性在每个人心中都心照不宣。我看到一个有小孩的家庭，他们只是把一只泰迪熊放在四个州交汇的地方，然后拍了一张它的照片。
Couldn't any four corners hold just as much meaning as this place? And my friend, the answer, of course, is yes. And today on our program, we offer our own little national monument here on the radio, our own picture of life in America, our own four corners. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
难道其他的任何一个角落就不能拥有和这个地方一样多的意义吗？我的朋友，答案当然是肯定的。今天在我们的节目中，我们在广播里为大家呈现我们自己的小小国家纪念碑，我们自己关于美国生活的写照，我们自己的四角落。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, Four Corners, we tell the story of life in America through portraits of life on four different corners in four different states across this great nation. Act One, History. Act Two, Love. Act Three, Neighbors. Act four, How to Become an American. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目《四角落》中，我们通过描绘这个伟大国家四个不同州、四个不同角落的生活，讲述美国的生活故事。第一幕，历史。第二幕，爱情。第三幕，邻居。第四幕，如何成为美国人。请继续收听。
Act One. Let us begin with the most epic of our four stories today. About a year ago, writer Sarah Vowell had a theory that she could tell the entire history of America by describing what happened on and around one single street corner. Specifically, the corner of Michigan Avenue and Wacker Drive here in Chicago. She thought she could just swivel around and point at the whole dark and inspiring tale. Here then, her story.
第一幕。让我们从今天四个故事中最宏大的一个开始。大约一年前，作家萨拉·沃维尔有一个理论：她可以通过描述单一街道角落上和周围发生的事情，讲述整个美国的历史。具体来说，就是芝加哥密歇根大道和瓦克大道的交汇处。她认为她只需环顾四周，就能指出整个黑暗而鼓舞人心的故事。下面就是她的故事。
When I started I had only a few things to go on, a couple of French explorers, a plaque on the bridge said, "Passed by in 1673." An Indian massacre in 1812 right there in front of the Burger King, vague notions of Abe Lincoln's debt to the Chicago Tribune , whose quaint Gothic tower looms over the bridge's north side. I thought, that's enough American history, and I'd just make up the rest.
当我开始时，我只有少量资料，桥上的一块牌匾写着：“1673年路过”。1812年在汉堡王前发生的一场印第安人大屠杀，关于林肯欠《芝加哥论坛报》债务的模糊概念，该报古雅的哥特式塔楼就耸立在桥的北侧。我想，这就足够涵盖美国历史了，剩下的我只需编造出来。
Turns out my theory was only too right. The intersection of Michigan and Wacker, I found out, isn't just a corner, it's a vortex. The deeper I dug into the history of Chicago and its relationship to the history of the country, the more crowded the ghost traffic jam clogging up the Michigan Avenue Bridge got.
事实证明，我的理论太正确了。我发现，密歇根大道和瓦克大道的交叉口不仅仅是一个角落，它是一个漩涡。我越深入挖掘芝加哥的历史及其与国家历史的关系，挤在密歇根大道桥上的“幽灵交通拥堵”就越严重。
OK, I'm standing here right now on the Michigan Avenue Bridge and the Chicago River is right underneath me. There are some ducks floating under there, and a boat just went by. And here's another one coming. Out there is where the river meets Lake Michigan to the east. And looking south, the place where the bridge hits land is the corner of Michigan Avenue and Wacker Drive, where you can get your vision checked or buy a nice fur coat, should you desire.
好的，我现在正站在密歇根大道桥上，芝加哥河就在我脚下。下面漂浮着一些鸭子，一艘船刚刚经过。又来了一艘。东边是河流汇入密歇根湖的地方。向南看，桥梁着陆的地方就是密歇根大道和瓦克大道的拐角处，如果你愿意，可以在那里检查视力或买一件漂亮的皮草大衣。
I'm swiveling around, and the view from the bridge is just picture postcard pretty, especially at night when the Wrigley Building is just lit up so soft it glows. Supposedly, the building so delighted Joseph Stalin that he had the University of Moscow designed in its image. And who can blame him?
我环顾四周，从桥上看到的景色就像明信片一样漂亮，尤其是在晚上，瑞格利大厦被照亮，柔和得发光。据说，这座建筑让约瑟夫·斯大林非常喜欢，以至于他让人仿照它的形象设计了莫斯科大学。谁又能怪他呢？
The American national mythology revolves around the idea that the promise of America is best seen in the West. Home, home, on the range, et cetera. Existentially, that might be true. But economically, the real place to witness the promise of America is the Midwest, where for most of this country's history, the products of the range were manipulated for fun and profit.
美国国家神话围绕着这样一个观点：美国的希望最能体现在西部。家，哦，家，在牧场等等。从存在主义上讲，那可能是真的。但在经济上，见证美国希望的真正地方是中西部，在那里，这个国家大部分历史中，牧场的产品被操纵以获取乐趣和利润。
When the cowboys sang, get along little dogie, they left out the part where the little dogie is railroaded to Chicago to be slaughtered by some underpaid, overworked immigrant en route to its manifest destiny as a New Yorker's supper.
当牛仔们唱着“跟上小牛”时，他们漏掉了一部分，即小牛被铁路运往芝加哥，被一些报酬过低、过度劳累的移民屠宰，在通往成为纽约人晚餐的“天命”途中。
The first person to grasp the significance of this place where the Chicago River meets Lake Michigan was Louis Joliet, or as he's known around here, Joliet. Back when his name was still said with a French accent, Joliet was a 27-year-old fur trader who accompanied a Jesuit missionary named Jacques Marquette on a canoe expedition from Quebec in 1673. They were to map the Mississippi in the name of France, unaware that Spain had already claimed the river some 130 years before.
第一个领会到芝加哥河与密歇根湖交汇处重要性的人是路易斯·乔利埃，或者正如这里所称的那样，乔利埃。当他的名字还带着法语口音时，乔利埃是一位27岁的毛皮商人，他陪同一位名叫雅克·马凯特的耶稣会传教士于1673年从魁北克出发进行独木舟探险。他们奉法国之名绘制密西西比河的地图，却不知西班牙早在130年前就声称拥有这条河流。
On the return trip, at the suggestion of their Indian guide, they traveled from the Mississippi into the Illinois River, and then the Des Plaines. They got out and carried their canoes a few dozen miles to the Chicago River, where they got back in their canoes and paddled to this very spot. Right where the river meets the Great Lakes, just below the corner at Michigan and Wacker.
在返回的路上，在印第安向导的建议下，他们从密西西比河前往伊利诺伊河，然后是德斯普兰斯河。他们下船，把独木舟搬了几十英里到芝加哥河，然后重新上船，划到了这个地方。就在河流与五大湖汇合的地方，就在密歇根和瓦克拐角处的下方。
And Joliet then had a vision. His map of North America-- an oddly pretty, delicate ink drawing he made in 1674-- is concerned with one thing and one thing only, water. His America is all Great Lakes and Mississippi. Look close, and you can see what he saw.
乔利埃当时有一个愿景。他的北美地图——他于1674年制作的一幅奇特而精致的墨水画——只关心一件事：水。他的美国全是五大湖和密西西比河。仔细看，你就能看到他所看到的。
There's Lake Michigan and at only one spot, the future site of Chicago, does it connect to a river that connects to a couple of other rivers that could connect it to the Mississippi. This is what Joliet saw, that this place is a continental hub, the missing link between the Great Lakes and the Mississippi, and thus the Atlantic and the Gulf. All that was needed was a short canal spanning the miles of prairie between rivers.
那里是密歇根湖，只有一个地方，即芝加哥的未来所在地，它连接着一条河流，这条河流又连接着另外几条河流，可以通往密西西比河。这就是乔利埃看到的，这个地方是一个大陆枢纽，是五大湖和密西西比河之间，也就是大西洋和墨西哥湾之间缺失的环节。所需要的只是一条横跨河流之间数英里草原的短运河。
He wrote, "We could go with facility to Florida in a bark, and by very easy navigation."
他写道：“我们可以轻松地乘小船前往佛罗里达，航行非常便利。”
Thus, Joliet's map isn't so much a map as a prophecy. Stick your ear up against it and you can practically hear cash registers ring.
因此，乔利埃的地图与其说是一张地图，不如说是一个预言。把耳朵贴上去，你几乎可以听到收银机在响。
Surprisingly, they only built a bridge here in 1920. Engineers also straightened out the Chicago River and put in massive landfills over there, so the lake is further from the corner than it was in Joliet's day. And I like to picture Joliet sometimes walking up or down Michigan Avenue to the bridge, a go cup in his hand from either the Starbucks over there from the north side of the river or the Starbucks over there on the south side of the river, spitting coffee-laced saliva into the Chicago River, knowing it will float with facility all the way past New Orleans and to the ocean from there.
令人惊讶的是，他们直到1920年才在这里建桥。工程师们还拉直了芝加哥河，在那里进行了大规模的填埋，所以湖泊比乔利埃时代离拐角处更远了。我有时喜欢想象乔利埃沿着密歇根大道走到桥上，手里拿着一杯咖啡——来自河北边的星巴克或者河南边的星巴克，把含着咖啡的唾液吐进芝加哥河，知道它能顺流而下，一路经过新奥尔良，直达海洋。
The first person to get cracking on Joliet's dream was Chicago's first permanent settler, Jean Baptiste Point du Sable, a trader who built a cabin here on the north side of the river in 1779, a century after Joliet paddled by. Du Sable's mother was an African slave and his father was French. He lived here on what is now the site of a 35 story office tower called the Equitable Building. With his Potawatomi wife, Catherine, Du Sable's marriage bed was itself a map of America, the mixing of European, African, and Indian blood to make a son and a daughter, true American children with three continents in their dark eyes.
第一个着手实现乔利埃梦想的人是芝加哥的第一位永久居民，让·巴蒂斯特·波因特·杜·萨布尔，一位商人在1779年，即乔利埃划船经过一个世纪后，在河的北岸建了一座小屋。杜·萨布尔的母亲是黑人奴隶，父亲是法国人。他住在现在一座名为公平大厦的35层办公楼所在地。他和波塔瓦托米族妻子凯瑟琳的婚姻本身就是一张美国的地图，欧洲、非洲和印第安血液的混合产生了一个儿子和一个女儿，真正的美国孩子，黑暗的眼睛里承载着三个大陆。
Chicago school teachers like to impress upon their students that Chicago's first resident, Du Sable, was a black man. And just think, it only took 204 years for the town to elect its first black mayor.
芝加哥的学校老师喜欢给学生留下深刻印象：芝加哥的第一位居民杜·萨布尔是个黑人。想想看，这座城市花了204年才选出第一位黑人市长。
In 1803, the United States established Fort Dearborn at what would become the corner of Michigan and Wacker to protect the portage of the Chicago River. During the War of 1812, hundreds of Potawatomi Indians descended upon the soldiers and their families and killed them, burning down the fort. The site of Chicago was then abandoned for four years. When soldiers arrived to rebuild the fort, they first had to bury the scalped human remains which still lay there.
1803年，美国在后来的密歇根和瓦克拐角处建立了迪尔伯恩堡，以保护芝加哥河的搬运点。1812年战争期间，数百名波塔瓦托米印第安人袭击了士兵及其家属，并将堡垒烧毁。芝加哥此后荒废了四年。当士兵们赶来重建堡垒时，他们首先必须掩埋仍然留在那里、被剥了头皮的人类遗骸。
Today, the site of the fort is weirdly commemorated here with these little bronze markers embedded in the sidewalk at Michigan and Wacker. So the tourists can dance around its former perimeter as if learning to cha, cha, cha.
今天，堡垒的遗址在这里以一种奇怪的方式被纪念，嵌入密歇根和瓦克人行道上的这些小铜质标记。这样游客们就可以围绕着它的前边界跳舞，仿佛在学跳恰恰舞。
And over here, there's a wildly racist relief sculpture commemorating the defense of Fort Dearborn, where a soldier from the fort is kind of battling off this savage Indian brave while a mother and child are kind of cowering behind him, basically waiting to die. And underneath that, is a plaque that says the people of the fort were brutally massacred by the Indians. They will be cherished as martyrs in our early history. What it doesn't say is that those Indians technically hadn't given over their rights to this land. But it looks like they ran out of room to put that on the plaque.
这边有一座极其种族主义的浮雕，纪念迪尔伯恩堡的防御，堡垒的一名士兵正在击退一名野蛮的印第安勇士，而一位母亲和孩子则缩在他身后，基本上在等待死亡。在它下面是一块牌匾，上面写着堡垒的人民被印第安人残忍屠杀。他们将在我们早期历史中被尊为烈士。它没有说的是，那些印第安人在法律上并没有放弃他们对这片土地的权利。看来牌匾上没有空间写这些了。
Now I'm going to walk around here back onto the bridge. And I'm looking west across the Chicago River. And if you look downriver at the turn in the river, a few blocks west, you can see the site of the old Sauganash Hotel right over there.
现在我要绕过这里回到桥上。我正向西望去，跨过芝加哥河。如果你顺流而下，往西几个街区，看向河的转弯处，你可以看到旧索加纳什酒店的旧址。
During the first half of the 19th century at the Sauganash Hotel, Chicagoans seemed to be play acting the juiciest bits of the country's spanking new Constitution every night. Historian Donald L. Miller writes, "At the Sauganash and its neighboring hotels, men and women of every color and class were welcome. And whiskey, song, and dance were the great democratizors.
在19世纪上半叶的索加纳什酒店，芝加哥人似乎每天晚上都在表演国家崭新宪法中最精彩的部分。历史学家唐纳德·L·米勒写道：“在索加纳什及其邻近的酒店里，欢迎各种肤色和阶层的人。威士忌、歌声和舞蹈是伟大的民主化力量。”
Visitors from more civilized parts were shocked to see Indian braves spinning the white wives of fort officers around the dance floor of the Sauganash to the frenzied fiddling and toe-tapping of hotel owner, Mark Beaubien. Or white and Indian women drinking home-distilled liquor straight from the bottle. To add an edge to the evenings, local white traders would put on feathered headdresses and spring into the crowded tavern with war whoops and raised tomahawks, scaring the wits out of tight-buttoned easterners."
来自更文明地区的游客看到印第安勇士在索加纳什的舞池里，随着酒店老板马克·博比恩疯狂的小提琴声和踢踏节奏，旋转着堡垒军官的白人妻子，感到非常震惊。或者看到白人和印第安妇女直接从瓶子里喝自制的酒。为了给夜晚增添刺激，当地的白人商人会戴上羽毛头饰，伴随着战嚎和挥舞的战斧冲进拥挤的酒馆，把那些拘谨的东部人吓得魂飞魄散。
I can not overemphasize how much I love that story. Not just the metaphor of it, that it is the best ideal of America I can think of. The picture of liquored up ladies and dancing Indians, the strangeness of reenacting the Fort Dearborn massacre to scare the queasy easterners, turning what must have still been an open wound into a practical joke. I love that story as proof of the theorem that then, as today in Chicago, the mysterious equation of whiskey plus music equals what can only be called happiness.
我无法过分强调我有多喜欢这个故事。不仅仅是它的比喻，它是我想象中美国最好的理想。酒气熏天的女士和跳舞的印第安人，重演迪尔伯恩堡大屠杀来吓唬那些娇气的东部人，把依然开放的伤口变成一个恶作剧的怪异场景。我喜欢这个故事，它证明了一个定理：当时和今天的芝加哥一样，威士忌加音乐的神秘方程式等于一种只能被称为幸福的东西。
The ladies of Chicago wouldn't be dancing with Indians much longer because there wouldn't be any Indians left to dance with. The city of Chicago was officially incorporated in 1833, the year the Potawatomi chief stood near the old Du Sable home and signed away their land in Illinois to the administration of Andrew Jackson, who found time in this busy schedule of relocating the Cherokee, Creek, Choctaw, Seminole and Chickasaw to have the Potawatomi removed west to what US government surveyors had called, "Land too poor for snakes to live upon."
芝加哥的女士们不会再和印第安人跳多久的舞了，因为不会再有印第安人可以一起跳舞了。芝加哥市于1833年正式成立，那一年波塔瓦托米酋长站在旧杜·萨布尔家附近，将他们在伊利诺伊州的土地签让给安德鲁·杰克逊的政府。杰克逊在忙于迁移切诺基、克里克、乔克托、塞米诺尔和奇卡索人之后，还有时间将波塔瓦托米人迁往西部，迁往美国政府测量员所称的“土地贫瘠到蛇都无法生存”的地方。
Three years after the Potawatomi signed away their land and the city was incorporated, construction began on that canal that Joliet had envisioned to connect Lake Michigan to the Mississippi. The canal worked pretty much exactly as Joliet had imagined. So much trade moved past this corner that Chicago expanded from a muddy little Hamlet of a few hundred people to a city of over 100,000 in just 25 years.
波塔瓦托米人签让土地三年后，城市成立，乔利埃设想的连接密歇根湖和密西西比河的运河开始动工。运河的运作几乎正如乔利埃所设想的那样。太多的贸易经过这个角落，芝加哥在短短25年内就从一个几百人的泥泞小村庄扩张成了一个拥有超过10万人口的城市。
Cyrus McCormick built his McCormick Reaper Works right here on the river in 1847. His machine, the reaper, turned out to be one of the most significant inventions in the history of history. Before McCormick, it took 3 hours to gather a bushel of wheat. And with the reaper, it took 10 minutes. Because McCormick helped mechanize agriculture, farms could take up more space and use less labor in less time. By speeding up and emptying out the country, McCormick populated the city. Not that the march of progress is necessarily benign, especially if you're one of those urban workers. Just ask the dead of the Haymarket riot who laid down their lives just 15 blocks from here for the 8 hour workday. Or read Upton Sinclair's The Jungle , about what the stockyard employees went through on the south side.
塞勒斯·麦考密克于1847年就在河边建造了他的麦考密克收割机厂。他的机器——收割机——成为了历史上最重要的发明之一。在麦考密克之前，收集一蒲式耳小麦需要3小时。有了收割机，只需要10分钟。因为麦考密克帮助实现了农业机械化，农场可以占用更多空间，用更少的时间和劳动力。通过加速并清空乡村，麦考密克填充了城市。并不是说进步的步伐一定是仁慈的，特别是如果你是那些城市工人之一的话。只要问问距离这里只有15个街区的干草市场暴乱中牺牲的人们，为了8小时工作制付出了生命。或者阅读厄普顿·辛克莱的《屠场》，了解南区肉联厂员工的遭遇。
By the Civil War, most of America's grain from the West and the vast prairie around Chicago was unloaded from trains here, traded on the commodities exchange, and then sent east on ships from Lake Michigan, all within a five minute walk of the corner of Michigan Avenue and Wacker Drive.
到了内战时期，美国西部和芝加哥周围广阔草原的大部分谷物都是在这里从火车上卸下，在商品交易所交易，然后从密歇根湖乘船向东运往，所有这些都在密歇根大道和瓦克大道拐角处步行五分钟的范围内。
It could have been this very spot the poet Carl Sandburg was thinking of in his famous poem about Chicago, "Hog Butcher to the World." He called the city, "Tool maker, stacker of wheat, player with railroads, and the nation's freight handler. Stormy, husky, brawling, city of the big shoulders."
诗人卡尔·桑德堡在他著名的芝加哥诗作“世界屠猪人”中，可能想到的正是这个地方。他称这座城市为：“工具制造者，小麦堆放者，铁路玩家，国家的货物搬运工。风暴般的、强壮的、吵闹的，大肩膀之城。”
So over here, tool maker. That was the reaper factory on the north side of the river. And over there, stacker of wheat on the south side. That was where these giant grain silos stood, where now is standing a giant Hyatt Hotel. The player with railroad and nation's freight handler, that's over there behind the Hyatt where the train tracks were. And look right there, the guy in the leather jacket, big shoulders.
所以这边是工具制造者。那是河的北侧收割机工厂。那边是小麦堆放者，在南侧。那是巨大的谷物筒仓所在的地方，现在耸立着一家巨大的凯悦酒店。铁路玩家和国家货物搬运工在凯悦酒店后面的那边，火车轨道所在的地方。看那边，那个穿皮夹克的家伙，大肩膀。
It is my project to tell the whole history of America from this corner. And there's no telling of that history without the Civil War.
我的计划是从这个角落讲述整个美国历史。没有内战，就没有那个历史的讲述。
Abraham Lincoln was nominated for president here in Chicago at the Republican National Convention in 1860, on the very site, by the way, of the old Sauganash Hotel, where the Indians and drunken ladies used to dance. And the Chicago Tribune, standing on North Michigan Avenue, a stone's throw from the bridge, not only campaigned for Lincoln, its editors talked him into running for president in the first place.
1860年，亚伯拉罕·林肯就在芝加哥的共和党全国代表大会上被提名为总统，顺便提一下，就在旧索加纳什酒店的原址上，也就是印第安人和醉酒女士过去跳舞的地方。距离桥仅一箭之遥、矗立在北密歇根大道的《芝加哥论坛报》，不仅为林肯竞选，其编辑们最初还说服他参选总统。
Lincoln was considering going for vice president. Maybe. The Trib 's great editor, Joseph Medill, helped found the Republican Party to advance the anti-slavery cause. Medill was such a passionate abolitionist that he wrote in a Tribune editorial in 1856, "We are not unfrequently told that we crowd the Tribune with anti-slavery matter to the exclusion of other topics. We plead guilty."
林肯当时在考虑竞选副总统。也许吧。《论坛报》的伟大编辑约瑟夫·梅迪尔帮助创立了共和党，以推动废奴事业。梅迪尔是一位如此热情的废奴主义者，以至于他在1856年的一篇《论坛报》社论中写道：“我们不时被告知，我们用反奴隶制内容挤满了《论坛报》，排挤了其他话题。我们认罪。”
Medill and company's access to the president wasn't necessarily always in their favor. At the height of the Civil War, they went to the White House and pleaded to get out of the president's new request for 6,000 more Union draftees from Cook County in Chicago. This after the area had already given up some 22,000 men. According to writer Lloyd Wendt, after Medill asked for mercy, Lincoln turned on him with that Lincolnesque biblical wrath, scolding, "It is you who are largely responsible for making blood flow as it has. You called for war until we had it. You called for emancipation, and I have given it to you. Whatever you have asked for, you have had. Now you come here begging to be let off from the call for men, which I have made to carry out the war you have demanded? You ought to be ashamed of yourselves. I have a right to expect better things of you. Go home and raise your 6,000 extra men."
梅迪尔和同事们对总统的访问并不总是对他们有利。在内战最激烈的时候，他们前往白宫，恳求总统撤回从芝加哥库克县征召6000名更多联邦士兵的新要求。这还是在该地区已经贡献了约2.2万名男丁之后。据作家劳埃德·温特说，在梅迪尔请求宽恕后，林肯带着林肯式的圣经愤怒转向他，责备道：“正是你们在很大程度上负责让血像现在这样流淌。你们呼吁战争，直到我们有了战争。你们呼吁解放，我给了你们。无论你们要求什么，你们都得到了。现在你们来到这里乞求撤回我为执行你们要求的战争而发出的征兵令？你们应该为自己感到羞耻。我有权期望你们做得更好。回家去，征集你们的6000名额外士兵。”
Needless to say, Lincoln got his Chicago soldiers. And reporting the news of the president's assassination on April 15, 1865, the headline of the Chicago Tribune simply reads, "Terrible News."
不用说，林肯得到了他的芝加哥士兵。在报道1865年4月15日总统遇刺的消息时，《芝加哥论坛报》的头条标题写道：“可怕的消息。”
Not long after the Civil War, the whole city burned to the ground, and Chicago became the place where every major architect in the country-- from Louis Sullivan and Frank Lloyd Wright on down to Mies van der Rohe-- worked on reinventing what a city skyline is supposed to look like. Montgomery Ward and Sears and Roebuck revolutionized consumer merchandising with mail order catalog sales. Montgomery Ward was just two blocks from Michigan and Wacker.
内战结束后不久，整个城市被烧毁，芝加哥成为了全国每位主要建筑师——从路易斯·萨利文和弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特到密斯·凡·德·罗——致力于重塑城市天际线的地方。蒙哥马利·沃德和西尔斯·罗巴克通过邮购目录销售彻底改变了消费者营销。蒙哥马利·沃德离密歇根和瓦克只有两个街区。
In 1920, Al Capone came to town, the same year prohibition went into effect. One year after that, Vincent "The Schemer" Drucci, a member of the Dean O'Banion gang, chased by police, drove onto the Michigan Avenue Bridge just as it was opening to let a boat pass. He jumped the gap only to crash straight into the other side.
1920年，阿尔·卡彭来到了城里，那也是禁酒令生效的一年。一年后，迪恩·欧班尼恩帮派成员文森特·“策划者”·德鲁奇在警察追捕下，开车上了密歇根大道桥，当时桥刚好为了让船通过而开启。他跳过缺口，结果直接撞到了另一边。
Decades pass. Manufacturing at the corner gives way to the service economy. Now it's all banks and advertising agencies and law firms. Skyscrapers, instead of warehouses. Railroads give way to the world's busiest airport on the north side of town.
几十年过去了。角落的制造业让位于服务业。现在到处都是银行、广告公司和律师事务所。摩天大楼取代了仓库。铁路让位于城北世界上最繁忙的机场。
If I may skip ahead in the interest of finishing this story before tomorrow morning's paper arrives-- for me, by the way, the Tribune, chock full of those anti-slavery screeds, as usual. Only an eight minute walk from the corner is the site of the first Kennedy-Nixon debate, the place you could argue where modern televised democracy begins. Since that's the debate Nixon was said to lose not because of the issues, but because he looked so ghastly, sweating under the lights.
为了在明天早上的报纸送达前写完这个故事，如果允许我跳过一些内容——顺便说一下，对我来说，《论坛报》通常充满了那些反奴隶制的文章。从拐角处步行仅八分钟就是第一场肯尼迪-尼克松辩论的地点，你可以说这是现代电视民主开始的地方。因为尼克松输掉那场辩论据说不是因为议题，而是因为他在灯光下流汗，看起来太糟糕了。
And just a short walk from there is the building where Hugh Hefner ran Playboy magazine during its heyday.
从那里步行不远就是休·海夫纳在鼎盛时期经营《花花公子》杂志的建筑。
As long as we're on the subject of the decline of Western civilization, if you look over there to the second story of the NBC Tower, tucked between the Equitable and the Tribune, that's where they tape the Jerry Springer Show.
既然我们谈到了西方文明的衰落，如果你看那边NBC大厦的二楼，夹在公平大厦和《论坛报》之间，那就是他们录制杰瑞·斯普林格秀的地方。
The Jerry Springer Show. It just wouldn't be the haunted landscape around the Michigan Avenue Bridge if some symbolic television apocalypse did not happen here each day. Booking guests whose near constant profanity makes this show into an unintelligible barrage of bleeps, watching it is like listening to a constant storm warning. Which is exactly what it is.
杰瑞·斯普林格秀。如果每天不在密歇根大道桥周围发生某种象征性的电视末日，那就不算是闹鬼的景观了。预订那些几乎不断使用亵渎语言的嘉宾，使这个节目变成了一连串难以理解的哔哔声，观看它就像听持续不断的风暴警报。这正是它所代表的。
Maybe it's just a coincidence, but one way you can measure the importance of this corner to our national psyche is the number of times it shows up in motion pictures, specifically the action adventure kind. Bruce Willis, Samuel Jackson, Kevin Costner, Sean Connery, Tommy Lee Jones, Wesley Snipes, Harrison Ford, Kevin Spacey. There's barely an actor worth the cover of Entertainment Weekly who hasn't been in a film with a scene shot right at the corner. And why? Because these films are about the motion of planes, trains, automobiles, boats, helicopters, motorcycles, every modern means of transportation. And so where better to film them than the place that three centuries ago was spotted as our country's leading transportation hub by Hollywood's favorite unintentional location scout, Louis Joliet?
也许只是巧合，但衡量这个角落对我们国家心理重要性的一种方式是它在电影中出现的次数，特别是动作冒险类电影。布鲁斯·威利斯、塞缪尔·杰克逊、凯文·科斯特纳、肖恩·康纳利、汤米·李·琼斯、韦斯利·斯奈普斯、哈里森·福特、凯文·斯派西。几乎没有哪个值得上《娱乐周刊》封面的演员没拍过在拐角处取景的电影场景。为什么？因为这些电影关于飞机、火车、汽车、船只、直升机、摩托车以及各种现代交通工具的运动。所以还有什么比三世纪前被好莱坞最不经意的外景探子路易斯·乔利埃发现为全国领先交通枢纽的地方更适合拍摄它们呢？
In one typical offering, Chain Reaction , Keanu Reeves plays a fugitive, motorcycle-riding University of Chicago machinist being framed for murder, treason, and terrorism. Being framed is usually a big part of all of these movies. Attempting to elude the police, he is chased down Michigan Avenue to the Michigan Avenue Bridge. The bridge starts opening and Keanu scurries up, a cop not far behind. He does a little better than Vincent "The Schemer" Drucci did in the '20s. But then, Keanu's a movie star, has a stunt double, and can do retakes.
在一个典型的作品《连锁反应》中，基努·里维斯饰演一名骑摩托车的芝加哥大学机械师逃犯，被诬陷犯有谋杀、叛国和恐怖主义罪。被诬陷通常是所有这些电影的重要组成部分。为了逃避警察，他被追赶到密歇根大道，到了密歇根大道桥。桥开始开启，基努跑了上去，警察紧随其后。他比20年代的文森特·“策划者”·德鲁奇表现得稍微好一点。但基努是个电影明星，有替身，可以重拍。
As the angle of the raised bridge gets steeper, the cop slides to the bottom. Keanu's at the top. What should he do? He looks up. A police helicopter. He looks down. A police boat. He crawls into the bottom of the bridge as it's lowered and ducks into a garbage truck to safety. When he meets his fellow shapely fugitive who nervously awaits him at the train station, the conductor asks, what took you so long? To which Keanu deadpans--
随着升起的桥面角度变陡，警察滑到底部。基努在顶部。他该怎么办？他抬头看。一架警用直升机。他往下看。一艘警用船。当桥放下时，他爬进桥底，躲进一辆垃圾车中脱险。当他在火车站遇到焦虑等待他的同伴逃犯时，乘务员问，你为什么这么慢？基努面无表情地回答——
The bridge was up.
桥升起来了。
Up, down, north, south, whatever. The point is that the bridge was right at the center of attention, in the middle of the action, at the hub.
升起、放下、北向、南向，随便吧。重点是桥就在关注的中心，处于动作的中间，在枢纽处。
We used to ship grain from this corner. Now that entertainment is America's second biggest export, the product we ship is Keanu.
我们过去从这个角落运送谷物。现在娱乐业是美国第二大出口产品，我们运送的产品是基努。
I don't know what you're talking about. Jesus.
我不知道你在说什么。天哪。
Sarah Vowell is a contributing editor to our program and a columnist for Salon, the online magazine.
萨拉·沃维尔是我们节目的特约编辑，也是在线杂志《Salon》的专栏作家。
Our program today about four different visions of America told at four different street corners across the country. We've arrived at Act Two, Love.
我们今天关于美国四个不同愿景的节目，讲述了全国四个不同街角的故事。我们进入了第二幕，爱情。
For Scott Richer and Julie Riggs, at the corner where South Fourth Street in Louisville, Kentucky, meets the alley behind the West End Baptist Church, things between them changed forever and irrevocably.
对于斯科特·里彻和朱莉·里格斯来说，在肯塔基州路易斯维尔市第四南街与西区浸信会教堂后巷交汇的那个角落，他们之间的事情永远地、不可撤回地改变了。
I think it built and built continually until it got to the point that brought us to the corner where everything was so outrageous, our emotions were so careening wildly out of control, that all we had to do was stand there and look at each other for it to be a monumental event in our lives.
我认为这种情绪不断积累，直到达到那个带我们来到那个角落的临界点，一切都太离谱了，我们的情绪完全失控，以至于我们只需要站在那里看着对方，就能成为我们生命中具有纪念意义的事件。
The situation was Scott and I had been madly obsessed with each other for years, but we had always just been friends. And I was in a relationship at the time. So on this summer day, in this time in our relationship, in our friendship when we were just friends, I stopped by his apartment or his house over on Broadway to visit him.
当时的情况是，斯科特和我多年来一直疯狂地迷恋着对方，但我们一直只是朋友。当时我处于一段恋爱关系中。所以在这个夏日，在我们友谊的这段时间里，当我们只是朋友时，我顺道去百老汇那边的公寓或房子看他。
We had a really nice afternoon. I think we hadn't seen each other for a few weeks. But when we saw each other, we always laughed and always had fun and always made each other happy.
我们度过了一个非常愉快的下午。我想我们已经有几周没见面了。但当我们见面时，我们总是大笑，总是很开心，总是让对方感到幸福。
And then Scott, was this a day for you that was of particular torture?
那么斯科特，这对你来说是特别痛苦的一天吗？
A lot of days when she came over it was. It was fun, but it was bittersweet. She's always able to go away from it being happy. Being like, oh, that was so much fun. And meanwhile, I'm sitting there going, this is horrible. How can she be happy about what's happening here? It was almost like twisting the knife. It was like, ah.
当她来的时候，很多日子都是这样。很有趣，但又苦乐参半。她总是能开心地离开。像说，哦，那太有趣了。而与此同时，我却坐在那里心想，这太糟糕了。她怎么能对正在发生的事情感到高兴呢？简直就像在伤口上撒盐。那种感觉，啊。
So then I got in my little red Volkswagen and left and said goodbye.
所以我坐进我的红色大众小车，离开了，说了再见。
I was sitting on the back porch of our house. This is a very Kentucky setting, a steamy, hot, summer afternoon. And my roommate, Jason, came out and sat down and could tell that I was affected by emotion. And he said something to the effect of, sometimes you would rather have a feast or a famine.
我当时坐在我们家的后门廊上。这是一个非常肯塔基式的背景，潮湿、炎热的夏日下午。我的室友杰森走出来坐下，看出我情绪受到了影响。他说了类似“有时候你宁愿经历饥荒也不愿经历盛宴”的话。
I think it was something about a drought or a flood.
我想是关于旱灾或洪灾的事情。
A drought or a flood, yes. So I decided, well, enough of this then. And I decided to take the gamble. And I got in my car and raced down Broadway in afternoon traffic, weaving in and out of cars trying to catch her.
旱灾或洪灾，是的。所以我决定，好吧，受够了。我决定赌一把。我坐进车里，在下午的交通流中沿着百老汇狂奔，在车流中穿梭，试图追上她。
And I'm just cruising along. I had left like 15 minutes before that, I think.
我只是在巡游。我想我是在那之前大约15分钟离开的。
Yeah, I had promised myself, well, if I catch up to her before we get to Central Park, then I'll pull her over and I'm going to kiss her.
是的，我向自己保证，如果我在到达中央公园之前追上她，那我就让她靠边停车，然后我要吻她。
And I did catch her like right at Central Park.
我确实在中央公园追上了她。
Right at Central Park. I'm driving in my car and I look over and there he is. And he's like, pull over, pull over. I'm like, what's going on, completely confused. So I pull over into this parking lot right on the corner into this South End Baptist Church Parking lot, and we both got out of our cars.
就在中央公园。我正在开车，往旁边一看，他就在那儿。他不停地叫：靠边，靠边。我就想，怎么回事，完全困惑。所以我靠边停进这个南区浸信会教堂停车场，就在拐角处，我们俩都下了车。
And we just kind of stood leaning against our respective cars, just kind of making not even small talk. It was just like--
我们只是站在各自的车旁靠着，甚至连寒暄都没有。感觉就像——
Everything around us kind of stopped and nothing moved. And it was impossible to describe.
周围的一切似乎都停止了，什么也没有动。那种感觉无法形容。
Everything around you stopped and nothing moved?
周围的一切停止了，什么也没有动？
You know like in a movie or in a dream. If you're having a dream, and everything's spinning really quickly. And then all of a sudden, just the one spot where you're standing stays still.
你知道就像在电影或梦里一样。如果你在做梦，周围的一切都在飞速旋转。然后突然间，你站着的地方静止不动了。
I have no idea what happened there. We both felt something tremendously powerful.
我不知道那里发生了什么。我们俩都感受到了一种极其强大的东西。
Our hearts were racing so fast. And all the background noise just kind of drops out, and all the colors get really saturated.
我们的心跳得很快。所有的背景噪音都消失了，所有的颜色都变得极其饱和。
So then you kissed her?
所以你吻了她？
No, no.
不，不。
Nothing happened. He just stood there.
什么也没发生。他只是站在那里。
Well, something must have happened, because we're here talking about it now. So what exactly did happen next?
好吧，肯定发生了什么，因为我们现在正在谈论它。那么接下来到底发生了什么？
I think what-- God. I don't know. Something happened. But it just seemed to me, it seemed like being there, that was my confirmation that there was something definitely still going on inside Julie that involved me. Everything wasn't hopeless.
我想……天哪。我不知道。发生了一些事情。但对我来说，站在那里，那是我的确认，确定朱莉内心深处确实还有关于我的东西。一切并没有绝望。
Every time I'd drive by the parking lot-- and I actually went there at least twice that I'm sure Scott doesn't know about, just sitting in the parking lot thinking, God.
每次我开车经过那个停车场——我敢肯定斯科特不知道我至少去过两次——只是坐在停车场里心想，天哪。
So here our story ends. Julie's old boyfriend lived a block from the corner. So she passed it every time she went to see him, and thought about that moment with Scott. And finally, ditched the boyfriend. She and Scott have been together for three years. They now live together.
所以我们的故事到此结束。朱莉的前男友住离拐角处一个街区远的地方。所以她每次去看他都会经过那里，并想起与斯科特的那一刻。最后，甩掉了男朋友。她和斯科特在一起已经三年了。他们现在住在一起。
The funny thing about the situation was it wasn't the first time that we were destined to have our first kiss and missed it.
关于这种情况有趣的是，这并不是我们第一次注定要初吻却错失它的时候。
Really?
真的吗？
Because we were in Paris together eight months earlier. And we're having a really great time and stayed up really late one night in the corridor of a youth hostel in Paris talking. And we should have kissed then, but we didn't.
因为八个月前我们在巴黎。我们玩得很开心，有一天晚上在巴黎一家青年旅社的走廊里聊得很晚。我们当时本该接吻的，但我们没有。
Because you were with the other guy?
因为你当时有另外那个家伙？
Because of the other guy.
因为那个家伙。
Yes, even after I broke up with the guy. It still took so long.
是的，即使在我甩了那个家伙之后。还是花了好长时间。
Oh really?
哦真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
How come?
为什么？
I wanted it to be perfect. I wanted it to be something--
我想让它变得完美。我想让它成为……
He wanted to wait till springtime upon a beautiful cliff somewhere. I don't know.
他想等到春天的某个美丽悬崖上。我不知道。
And you know, when we were in Paris, I thought, well, there's the other guy. And we're in Paris. And you're supposed to fall in love in Paris, so we can't do it here. It's so typical to be in Paris. Oh, our first kiss was in Paris. I didn't want to be a Hallmark card. You only have one opportunity to have your first kiss with someone.
你知道，当我们在巴黎时，我想，好吧，还有那个家伙。我们在巴黎。你应该在巴黎坠入爱河，所以我们不能在那里做。那是多么典型，在巴黎。哦，我们的初吻是在巴黎。我不想成为一张贺卡。你一生只有一次机会与某人拥有初吻。
And you missed so many of them.
你们错过了这么多机会。
They finally had their first kiss in Scott's living room. She had to make the first move.
他们终于在斯科特的客厅里有了初吻。她必须迈出第一步。
Coming up, dogs, dead people, and a mystery. And what it takes to become an American. That's in a minute from Public Radio international. when our program continues.
稍后，关于狗、死人和一个谜团。以及成为美国人需要什么。来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Four Corners. We attempt to bring you a portrait of life in America by telling four different stories of four different street corners in four different parts of the country.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《四角落》。我们试图通过讲述全国四个不同地区、四个不同街角的故事，为您带来一幅美国生活的图景。
So far on our program we've heard about the past, we've heard about matters of the heart, and now we have arrived at Act Three, Neighbors. Mike Paterniti has this story of what makes a community in a cemetery in Portland, Maine, whose entrance stands at the corner of Vaughn and Clifford.
到目前为止，我们听到了关于过去、关于内心深处的事，现在我们进入第三幕，邻居。迈克·帕特尼蒂讲述了这个故事，关于在缅因州波特兰市一个入口位于沃恩和克利福德拐角处的墓地里，什么造就了一个社区。
The West End Cemetery is full of old dead sea captains and soldiers from the War of 1812. Kids that died of cholera and wives who, after 6 or 8 or 10 children, just gave up. There are rich people under monuments, the Longfellow family in a vault and paupers without so much as a wooden marker. No one's been buried here since the middle of this century. And so the place has fallen into disrepair. You see a lot of the marble and shale headstones in puzzle pieces on the ground or standing at crooked attention.
西区墓地里满是古老的死海员和1812年战争的士兵。死于霍乱的孩子们，以及生了6个、8个或10个孩子后就撒手人寰的妻子们。纪念碑下有富人，朗费罗家族在墓窖里，而穷人连个木牌都没有。本世纪中叶以来，没有人再埋葬在这里。所以这个地方变得破败不堪。你会看到许多大理石和页岩墓碑像拼图碎片一样散落在地上，或者歪斜地伫立着。
About 10 years ago, the cemetery was a popular hangout for prostitutes and junkies. But now it's just dogs and their owners.
大约10年前，这个墓地是妓女和瘾君子常去的地方。但现在，只有狗和它们的主人了。
[DOGS BARKING]
[狗叫声]
When I first moved to town a couple years ago with my girlfriend, Sarah, we walked our dog in the cemetery. There was this guy there named Jeff, a big, brawny American Indian, from the Duckwater tribe I think, who sort of qualified as my first friend in Portland.
几年前我和女朋友萨拉搬到城里时，我们在墓地遛狗。那里有个叫杰夫的家伙，一个魁梧的美国印第安人，我想来自鸭水部落，他算是我在波特兰的第一个朋友。
He told me how he grew up in Nevada and was adopted by white parents, and then raised in a little redneck town where people didn't really like Indians. He'd moved around a lot. And I pictured him as I was now, the stranger in a strange place. He walked with me in the cemetery, sometimes twice a day, whatever the weather. Or rather, we were both being walked by our dogs. His was a wolf mix named Keana, with a vacant, slightly menacing glint in her eye, who liked to rough up young puppies. And mine is a simple mutt named Trout, whose passion for chasing squirrels follows her lifelong commitment to rolling in poop.
他告诉我他是在内华达州长大的，被白人父母收养，然后在一个人人都不太喜欢印第安人的红脖子小镇长大。他搬了很多次家。我把他想象成现在的我，异乡的陌生人。他陪我在墓地散步，有时一天两次，无论天气如何。或者更确切地说，我们都被各自的狗遛着。他的是一只叫基安娜的狼混血狗，眼神中带着空洞、略显威胁的闪光，喜欢欺负幼犬。我的是一只叫特劳特的普通杂种狗，它追逐松鼠的热情，仅仅跟它一生致力于在粪便里打滚的爱好相当。
It seemed like Jeff was always at the cemetery, sometimes up to eight hours in a row. He said he worked at night, supposedly for a local scuba diving outfit, and that's why he had so much free time during the day. He told stories, endless stories about his high school football exploits and the blown-out knee that ended his college career at safety. He talked about fishing, how he gill netted in the rivers of Southeast Alaska, and then how he and his girlfriend had bought a house and now they weren't together anymore, and she had the house, and he was here, a country away, walking his dog with people like me.
杰夫似乎总是在墓地，有时一待就是八个小时。他说他在晚上工作，据说是一家当地的深海潜水机构，这就是为什么他在白天有这么多空闲时间。他讲故事，讲他高中足球的成就，讲结束了他大学安全卫职业生涯的膝盖报废，讲无尽的故事。他谈论钓鱼，他如何在阿拉斯加东南部的河流中用刺网捕鱼，然后他和女朋友买了一所房子，现在他们不在一起了，她拥有那所房子，而他在这里，远隔千里，和像我这样的人一起遛狗。
He didn't seem angry at all. No, in fact, he seemed happy. Like every day he was as happy as he had been the day before. And because of it, he was good at drawing people out, at connecting the various factions inside the cemetery so that everyone stood around, nodding dumbly, listening to Jeff, our oblivious mayor, holding forth on Keana's new collar or perfect shampoo while Keana took her pound of flesh out of some hapless pup.
他似乎一点也不生气。不，事实上，他看起来很开心。就像每一天他都像前一天一样开心。正因为如此，他擅长引出人们的话题，将墓地内的各个派系联系起来，以至于每个人都站在那里，愚笨地点着头，听着杰夫——我们健忘的市长——在基安娜咬伤某只不幸的小狗时，谈论她的新项圈或完美的洗发水。
This was not the way things usually worked in the cemetery. The mere fact that I knew Jeff's name was unusual. Usually people didn't interact that much. Instead, we knew each other by handles. There was dalmatian man, father of three speckled dogs, one to whom he spoke in sign language. There was greyhound lady, regally walking her trio of greyhounds until the day that Lightning, her beloved, dove through a plate glass window during a thunderstorm and died. There was the man who walks and reads. And frisbee dude. And the lawn chair family, an old father and his 50 something son who daily set up their folding chairs near the cemetery gate. And the pick-up artist around whom no one was safe. And there was crazy shouting man, owner of three rag-tag mutts and an elder statesman of the cemetery who when I finally talked to him wasn't crazy shouting man at all. His name was Al.
这通常不是墓地里运作的方式。我认识杰夫名字这一事实本身就不寻常。通常人们互动没那么多。相反，我们通过标签认识彼此。有大麦町人，三个斑点狗的父亲，他用手语跟其中一只交流。有灰狗女士，带着她的三只灰狗高贵地行走，直到有一天，她的爱犬“闪电”在雷雨中穿过玻璃窗死去。有那个边走边读的男人。还有飞盘哥。还有折叠椅家庭，一位老父亲和他50多岁的儿子，每天在墓地门口摆放他们的折叠椅。还有搭讪艺术家，他周围没人是安全的。还有疯狂的叫喊男，三只杂乱无章的杂种狗的主人，墓地的元老，当我终于跟他说话时，他根本不是什么疯狂叫喊男。他叫阿尔。
There are loads of people up there that I see all the time-- some of them I've been seeing for years-- and I don't know their names. I recognize them, they recognize me. We talk about all sorts of things. And it just never really occurs to you to ask their name because you know their dog's name.
墓地里有很多我经常见到的人——有些人我已经见了几年了——但我不知道他们的名字。我认出他们，他们认出我。我们谈论各种事情。你从来没想到问他们的名字，因为你知道他们狗的名字。
As a matter of fact, I've always had these funny occasions where you run into people that you've talked to a lot at the cemetery and you meet them somewhere. We were down at Granny Killam's when it was open one night. This woman came over and said, Al, how are you? How's the dogs? How's all this? And I was with a bunch of friends and I thought, and this is-- and I realized it wasn't that I had forgotten her name, it was that I'd never known her name. I knew her dog. I had no idea. This was not somebody that I just knew very casually. This was somebody I probably walked with three or four mornings a week.
事实上，我总是有这些有趣的场合，你在墓地里碰见谈论过很多次的人，然后在别处遇到他们。有天晚上格拉尼·基勒姆店开门的时候，我们都在那儿。这个女人走过来说，阿尔，你好吗？狗怎么样？这些都怎么样？我当时和一帮朋友在一起，我想，而且这是——我意识到不是我忘了她的名字，而是我从来不知道她的名字。我知道她的狗。我一点也不知道。这不是我只随便认识的人。这是我可能每周有三四个早晨一起散步的人。
But you always find you know a lot more dogs than you know people, which I think says something about who's worth knowing anyway.
但你会发现你认识的狗的名字比人名多得多，我认为这本身就说明了谁才值得认识。
Even today, what strikes me as amazing about the cemetery is that there are people here, people who show up twice a day and see other people here twice a day for years. And many of them just don't know each other's real name, let alone what the other does for a living, or dreams of at night, or loves, or hates. They just know each others' dog's name. So when they refer to one another they might say, Circe's mom said Milk Bones are full of preservatives, which is why she cooks her own. Or when they bump into each other downtown Christmas shopping they'll say, Elroy's mom. And then with nothing left to say say, how goes it?
即使在今天，墓地令我感到惊奇的是，这里有人，有些人每天出现两次，而且已经在这里连续几年每天见到其他人两次。他们中的许多人甚至不知道对方的真名，更不用说对方做什么工作，或者晚上梦想什么，爱什么，恨什么。他们只知道彼此狗的名字。所以当他们提到彼此时，他们可能会说，“瑟茜的妈妈说牛奶骨头里全是防腐剂，这就是为什么她自己做。”或者当他们在市中心买圣诞礼物时碰面，他们会说，“埃尔罗伊的妈妈。”然后没什么可说的，就问，“怎么样？”
Was this intimacy or a complete lack of intimacy? Sometimes it felt like both at once. You had the warmth of intimacy and the comfort of hiding behind your dog. And yet, every day you saw people at their most naked, talking baby talk to their hounds, kneeling to pick up poop. I asked my friend Julie, Reuben's mother, about this.
这是一种亲密还是完全缺乏亲密？有时感觉两者皆有。你有亲密的温暖，也有躲在狗身后的舒适。然而，每一天你都看到人们最赤裸的一面，用婴儿语跟他们的猎犬说话，跪下捡拾粪便。我问我的朋友朱莉——鲁本的妈妈——关于这个。
I think you really get sort of a window into people's-- I don't want to say-- well, into people's souls. You watch people very contentedly walking around, throwing the ball, interacting with their dogs, or totally ignoring their dogs, and going at their own pace, and every once in a while yelling for their dog.
我觉得你真的看到了人们内心的——我不想说——好吧，看到了人们的灵魂。你看人们非常满足地四处走动，扔球，与他们的狗互动，或者完全无视他们的狗，按自己的节奏走，偶尔大声喊叫他们的狗。
I mean, I really judge people by how they behave toward their dog.
我是说，我真的通过人们对待狗的行为来评价他们。
Here's Al again.
再听一遍阿尔的说法。
I mean, when I see people hit a dog, I'm really sort of appalled and amazed that you would do that. I know who really, really likes their dogs and who doesn't. I know people who have got trophy dogs and people who have got the scruffiest, ugliest dog, but they really, really love that dog.
我的意思是，当我看到人们打狗时，我真的很震惊，我很惊讶你会那样做。我知道谁真心非常喜欢他们的狗，谁不喜欢。我知道有些人有奖杯犬，有些人有最粗糙、最丑陋的狗，但他们确实非常、非常爱那条狗。
I think it was the love part that kept me going back to the cemetery. And then it became my social hour, my escape, where more often than not I'd find Jeff and Keana. The minute Jeff realized that I was a writer, he went to the library, and, over the course of the week, read everything I'd ever written. And then, to my horror, wanted to talk about it. And he did this kind of thing with others too.
我认为正是爱的部分让我不断回到墓地。然后它成了我的社交时间，我的避风港，在那里我经常能找到杰夫和基安娜。杰夫意识到我是个作家后，他去图书馆，在接下来的一周里读了我写的所有东西。然后，令我恐惧的是，他想谈论它。他对别人也这样做。
When the leaves began to change during my first October in the West End Cemetery, Jeff was already talking about a Christmas card he was planning, a photograph of Keana and himself. He brought it up obsessively. About how Keana was going to have a haircut and shampoo and have her nails clipped. And how he had arranged for a photographer, and how they were scouting locations. There were ups and downs in the saga as it played out over weeks. A good location that might not work out the day of the shoot if a nor'easter hit. The need to time everything just perfectly so that Keana would leave the beauty parlor and then immediately sit for a picture before she could come back to the cemetery and get muddy.
在我西区墓地的第一个十月，当树叶开始变色时，杰夫已经在谈论他正在计划的一张圣诞贺卡，一张基安娜和他的照片。他反复提起这件事。关于基安娜要剪头发、洗澡和修剪指甲。关于他已经安排好摄影师，以及他们如何去勘察地点。在接下来的几周里，这件事经历了不少波折。一个好的地点可能因为一场东北风暴而在拍摄当天无法使用。需要完美地把握时间，这样基安娜在美容院结束后可以立即坐下来拍照，以免她回到墓地弄得满身泥泞。
In retrospect, there were little clues even then that something strange was going on with Jeff. While he said he owned a truck, I only ever saw him at bus stops around town. And the scuba diving, later when I called various outfits in Portland, no one had ever heard of him. In the end, he had the photograph taken at Sears. He and Keana in the stiff, unsmiling pose of a Civil War era husband and wife.
回想起来，那时候就有小线索表明杰夫有些奇怪。虽然他说他有一辆卡车，但我只在城里的公交车站看到过他。还有关于深海潜水的事，后来我给波特兰的几个机构打电话，没人听说过他。最后，他在西尔斯拍了照片。他和基安娜摆出了内战时期丈夫和妻子那种僵硬、不苟言笑的姿势。
He in his familiar blue sweatshirt hulking behind Keana, who was perfectly coiffed. He was beaming when he handed the Christmas card to me. Literally beaming.
他穿着他那件熟悉的蓝色运动衫，魁梧地躲在完美的基安娜身后。他把圣诞贺卡递给我时，满脸放光。真的是满脸放光。
After Christmas I left the country for several weeks. And when I came back sometime after a massive ice storm, he was nowhere to be found. The cemetery glittered with glazed headstones. It took days to unravel the story because people didn't seem to want to talk about it, didn't seem to want to talk about anything. Everyone just bundled into themselves. And Jeff, he was a very touchy subject, one that suddenly made us all feel defensive.
圣诞节后我离开国家几周。当我回来时，在一场大规模冰暴之后，他不见踪影。墓地闪烁着冰封的墓碑。花了好几天才理清故事，因为人们似乎不想谈论它，似乎不想谈论任何事情。每个人都把自己封闭起来。而杰夫是一个非常敏感的话题，这突然让我们所有人都感到防御。
What I learned was this. He'd had health problems, an infection of some kind. He went to the hospital at the same time that he was apparently forced out of his apartment. Money was tight. He'd asked someone from the cemetery to put him up. Another line crossed, but that hadn't worked out. Keana was taken to a kennel by Meeghan, Maddie's mom. And now she was calling the kennel regularly to see if Jeff had picked her up, but he hadn't. Week after week, she called until it was clear that Jeff couldn't or wouldn't pick up Keana. That he was gone. That's when Keana was adopted by someone else. Here's Meeghan.
我了解到的是：他有健康问题，某种感染。他住院的同时，显然被迫离开了公寓。钱很紧。他曾请求墓地里的某个人收留他。又跨过了一条界线，但这没成功。基安娜被麦迪的妈妈米根带到了狗窝。现在她经常给狗窝打电话，看杰夫有没有去接她，但他没有。她一周又一周地打电话，直到清楚杰夫不能或者不会去接基安娜。他走了。那时候基安娜被别人领养了。下面是米根。
You start talking about this stuff with somebody, and then you realize, I didn't even know this person. Like with Jeff, it was like you knew everything about his life. But in the end, how much of that was actually true? And you didn't even know this person. It was like August to December and he was gone. But it seemed like forever.
你开始和某人谈论这些事，然后你意识到，我甚至根本不认识这个人。就像杰夫，感觉就像你了解他生活的一切。但最后，其中有多少是真实发生的？你甚至根本不认识这个人。就像八月到十二月，然后他就走了。但感觉像是永远。
There were completely unsubstantiated rumors that he had robbed a bank. Someone knew someone whose cousin had seen his photo on a Boston newscast, maybe. But then most people were quick to accept this as fact. In a weird way, I wonder if we felt betrayed, betrayed because Jeff had broken the simple rules of the cemetery. He had become too intimate. Now he was gone. And it was hard to say hi, let alone catch someone else's eye.
有一些完全未经证实的谣言说他抢了一家银行。有人认识某人的表弟，说在波士顿的电视节目上可能见过他的照片。但大多数人很快就接受这个事实。以一种奇怪的方式，我想知道我们是否感到被背叛，被背叛是因为杰夫打破了墓地的简单规则。他变得太亲密了。现在他走了。很难说声嗨，更不用说与别人的眼神交会了。
During those dark winter months, the cemetery became a kind of haunted, trustless place. In one of the endless conversations we had about him later, some people worried that he knew where we lived. Someone threatened to track him down. But what for? So that he might never again bamboozle other hapless dog owners in other seaside towns into chatting about doggie shampoo?
在那个黑暗的冬天，墓地变成了一个鬼气森森、互不信任的地方。后来我们关于他的无尽对话中，有些人担心他知道我们住在哪儿。有人威胁要追踪他。但为了什么？为了让他以后永远不会再在其他海边小镇骗那些不幸的狗主人聊天谈论洗发水吗？
Sarah and I kept the Christmas card on our refrigerator, right up until a couple months ago, actually, when it quietly fell to a new rotation of refrigerator photos. We kept it there in hopes, I think, that he would come back and explain where he'd been. For I was pretty certain he couldn't have robbed a bank. And if he had, I told myself, maybe it was because he had to. Maybe he'd been inches from a life he'd imagined for himself, with a dog that gave unconditional love. With friends he was guaranteed to see every day. And he'd had a couple of bad breaks. Got sick, ran out of money, lost his dog, and then panicked.
萨拉和我一直把那张圣诞贺卡贴在冰箱上，直到几个月前，当它静静地落入冰箱照片的新一轮更换中。我们把它贴在那里，我想，是希望他会回来解释他去了哪儿。因为我相当确定他不可能抢过银行。如果他抢了，我告诉自己，也许是因为他不得不这样做。也许他离自己想象的生活只差几英寸，拥有一只给予无条件爱的狗。拥有保证每天都能见到的朋友。而他遇到了一些倒霉事。生病了，钱花光了，丢了狗，然后惊慌失措。
Now time has passed. People come and go, and every six months the galaxy inside these gates breaks apart and reconfigures. Dogs die, people leave for nursing homes, others move, more arrive. And every day, today even, people are here walking in spectral circles like they're in Mecca, circling the Kaaba. In general, I'd say things are back to the way they were. Intimate, but not intimate. We stand around in dumbfounded joy with 10, 20, 30 other gaping grown adults, reveling in the simplicity of stupidly entertaining dog play.
现在时间过去了。人们来来去去，每六个月，这些大门内的星系就会分崩离析并重新组合。狗死了，人们搬进养老院，其他人搬走，更多人到达。每一天，甚至今天，人们在这里幽灵般地围成圆圈行走，就像他们在麦加，环绕着天房。总的来说，我会说事情回到了以前的样子。亲密，但又不亲密。我们和另外10个、20个、30个目瞪口呆的成年人一起站在那里，享受着愚蠢而有趣的狗嬉戏的简单。
Dalmatian man still flashes sign language at his deaf dalmatian. The pick-up artist still works his magic. The lawn chair family still sets up by the cemetery gate each day and cover their legs with wool blankets.
大麦町人仍然对他的聋大麦町犬打手语。搭讪艺术家仍然发挥他的魔力。折叠椅家庭每天仍然在墓地门口安营扎寨，用羊毛毯盖住他们的腿。
The fact is, even without somebody like Jeff pulling people together, if you stand on a corner with a bunch of strangers for long enough, eventually something happens that brings you together, sometimes something small.
事实是，即使没有像杰夫这样的人把人们聚在一起，如果你在拐角处和一群陌生人站得够久，最终会发生一些把你们聚在一起的事情，有时是些小事。
The other night I went to the cemetery at sunset. There were the same broken headstones, the same sea captains and paupers. And there were all these living people too, who only know me as Trout's dad, or as the guy who stupidly named his dog Trout, or however they see me.
那天晚上我日落时去了墓地。还有那些破损的墓碑，同样的海员和穷人。还有所有这些活人，他们只认识我是特劳特的爸爸，或者是那个愚蠢地给他的狗取名特劳特的家伙，或者他们眼中的我。
The dogs were playing hard, racing in circles, not wanting any of it to end and a gigantic moon came up, came up tangerine. It was the kind of moon that stills everything. And we stood in a circle, watching it rise. For a minute or two, we just stood there, it glowing orange. The dogs didn't exist at all.
狗在尽情玩耍，在圈子里奔跑，不想让这一切结束，一个巨大的月亮升起来了，升起的是橘黄色。那是那种让一切都静止下来的月亮。我们站在一个圈里，看着它升起。一两分钟，我们只是站在那儿，它发着橘光。狗根本不存在了。
Mike Paterniti lives in Portland, Maine.
迈克·帕特尼蒂住在缅因州波特兰市。
Act Four, How to Become an American. We have this story about a few of the things that are hard to understand, standing on a corner, when you come to this country. It's from Achy Obejas.
第四幕，如何成为美国人。我们有这个故事，关于当你来到这个国家时，站在角落里有一些很难理解的事情。它来自阿奇·奥贝亚斯。
It was exactly noon, and the last of the weekend breakfast crowd filtered out of the diner. From the booth-lined back wall, a young woman made her way to the front to pay her check. She was tall, with reddish brown hair to her shoulders. She had a tattoo on her left wrist, a delicately etched silver and green double-headed ax. All around her, the bus boys and waitresses kept moving, the dishes clattering on the large trays.
正是中午，最后的一批周末早餐人群走出了餐厅。从排着卡座的后墙边，一位年轻女性走上前去买单。她很高，有一头红褐色的齐肩长发。她的左手腕上有一个纹身，一把精致蚀刻的银绿色双头斧。在她周围，餐厅的杂工和服务员不断走动，盘子在巨大的托盘上叮当作响。
Lupe, a voice called from behind her. She turned around, then frowned. Standing next to her was a dark, stocky young man, a few black hairs poking sharply out of his chin. He smiled sheepishly. He carried a tray of improbably balanced plates and glasses.
“卢佩，”她身后一个声音叫道。她转过身，然后皱起眉头。站在她旁边的是一个肤色黝黑、身材结实的年轻男子，下巴上戳出几根硬硬的黑毛。他羞涩地笑了笑。他端着一个盘子和杯子，平衡得有些不可思议。
Hello, Raul, she said, resigned to his recognition. I didn't realize you worked here.
“你好，劳尔，”她说，顺从地接受了他的认出。“我没意识到你在工作。”
Yes, he said. His English too formal, crackling with Spanish underneath. He glanced at the ax on her wrist. Pedro got a job here, then he brought me. I've been here a few months already, so I should be a waiter soon. My English is much better now don't you think, he asked. The dishes on the tray rattled as he struggled to keep them from crashing to the floor.
“是的，”他说。他的英语太正式了，下面噼里啪啦地夹杂着西班牙语。他瞥了一眼她手腕上的斧头。“佩德罗在这里找了份工作，然后他带我来了。我已经在这里几个月了，所以我很快就能当服务员了。我的英语好多了，不是吗？”他问道。托盘上的盘子在他努力不让它们摔到地上时发出响声。
Yes, she said, starting out the door of the diner. Raul hurried to get rid of the tray and followed her out to the corner. She pulled on her sunglasses.
“是的，”她说，开始走出餐厅的门。劳尔急忙摆脱托盘，跟着她走到拐角处。她戴上了太阳镜。
I haven't seen you in a long time, he said, now in Spanish. She noticed him studying her hands and made a fist, which caused the ax to expand.
“我很久没见到你了，”他说，现在用西班牙语说。她注意到他注视着她的手，握成了拳头，这使得斧头看起来变大了。
I haven't seen you since, well, you know. You said some very cruel things, he continued. But I always look for you anyway, out in the streets, wondering how you are. You could've called.
“我自从……好吧，你知道以来就没见过你。你说了些非常残忍的话，”他继续说。“但我总是到处找你，在街上，想知道你怎么样。你本可以打电话的。”
What for?
“为了什么？”
Just then a pair of young men walked around them. One carrying a sheath of flyers, the other a roll of tape and a stapler. They stopped and put up some of the papers on the telephone pole next to them. The two men, young and girlish, left after they had layered the pole with announcements about an upcoming dance contest at a local club.
就在这时，一对年轻人从他们身边走过。一个拿着一叠传单，另一个拿着一卷胶带和一把订书机。他们停下来，把一些纸贴在旁边的电线杆上。这两个人，年轻又有些女性化，在铺满传单后离开了，那是关于当地俱乐部即将举行的舞蹈比赛的公告。
Lupe lowered her glasses enough to read and register the information. Raul watched her.
卢佩把眼镜摘下一点，阅读并登记了信息。劳尔看着她。
Well, you could call sometimes just to call. Not for anything in particular, but to let me know how you are. I worry about you, he said.
“好吧，你有时可以打电话，只是打个电话。不是为了什么特别的事，而是让我知道你怎么样。我担心你，”他说。
I'm sorry I didn't call, Lupe said. She pushed the glasses back up her nose.
“抱歉我没打，”卢佩说。她把眼镜推回鼻梁上。
It's just that, Raul said pouting, I mean, we're married after all. Lupe laughed.
“只是因为，”劳尔撅着嘴说，“我的意思是，我们毕竟是夫妻。”卢佩笑了。
No, Raul, you're married, she said. You knew damn well this was just a convenience for me, a business deal. I can't help it that you've spun all these stories for your family.
“不，劳尔，你是结了婚，”她说。“你很清楚这对我来说只是权宜之计，一笔交易。我没办法，你为你的家人编造了所有这些故事。”
But it's not right, Raul said. I thought we would live together.
“但这不对，”劳尔说。“我以为我们会住在一起。”
I never agreed to that. If it had been a condition, I never would have married you. She was squinting, her mouth was dry.
“我从没同意过。如果这是个条件，我就不会嫁给你。”她眯着眼睛，嘴里很干。
You paid me for something. All I'm doing is keeping my end of the bargain. And that doesn't include hanging around with you, your friends, or your family.
“你为某事付了我钱。我所做的一切只是履行我的协议。这不包括和你、你的朋友或你的家人混在一起。”
Well, I think you need me, he said, his lower lip jutting out like a fleshy ledge. I'm a good man. I can help you.
“好吧，我觉得你需要我，”他说，下唇像一块多肉的突起一样撅着。“我是个好人。我可以帮你。”
You don't get it, Raul, Lupe said, shifting her weight from one hip to the other. She stood at an angle, scratched her hand. I don't know that you'll ever get it. But suffice it to say, that I don't need you. We're not family. No matter how many justices of the peace we stand in front of.
“你不明白，劳尔，”卢佩说，重心从一边臀部移到另一边。她站在一个斜角，抓了抓手。“我不知道你是否能明白。但 suffice 来说，我不需要你。我们不是家人。无论我们站在多少个治安法官面前。”
But of course we are.
“但我们当然是。”
No, Raul. You have your people and I have mine.
“不，劳尔。你有你的人，我有我的人。”
But yours, that's not your family. You need me to help you stay in touch with your family. With your Latin self, he said angrily. He shoved one hand in his pants pocket and used the other to poke at the air. In Mexico, this wouldn't happen, and you'd have to do as I say. There are laws you know.
“但你那个，那不是你的家人。你需要我帮你和你的家人保持联系。和你的拉丁自我，”他愤怒地说。他把一只手塞进裤兜，用另一只手戳着空气。“在墨西哥，这不会发生，你得听我的。你知道法律的。”
Lupe laughed again. In Mexico, we'd never have married, Raul. In Mexico, you wouldn't need to marry a nice American girl.
卢佩又笑了。“在墨西哥，我们永远不会结婚，劳尔。在墨西哥，你不需要娶个漂亮的美国女孩。”
That you're American is an accident of geography, he said. You're running away from your Latin self he insisted. I know who you are. And I know who you think you are. I'm a man who has seen a little bit of the world. I may not have gone to college like you, but I know people and I know you.
“你是美国人只是地理上的意外，”他说。“你是在逃避你的拉丁自我，”他坚持道。“我知道你是谁。我知道你以为你是谁。我是个见过一点世面的男人。我可能不像你那样上过大学，但我认识人，我了解你。”
Oh, please, she said, and started to walk away from the corner. He shook his head sadly and looked down at the tips of his grime-covered shoes. Then he took off, following a few steps behind her.
“哦，拜托，”她说，开始离开那个角落。他悲伤地摇了摇头，看着他满是灰尘的鞋尖。然后他出发了，跟在她身后几步远。
I didn't want to do this, he said. But you've given me no choice. Suddenly he grabbed her and threw her against the flyer-covered telephone pole.
“我不想这样做，”他说。“但你没给我选择。”突然，他抓住她，把她扔向贴满传单的电线杆。
What the [BLEEP] do you think you're doing?, she demanded, kicking and scratching at him.
“你觉得你在做什么，[哔]？”她质问道，踢打着他。
I didn't want to hurt you, he said in a voice that cracked. I tried to carry this around with me all by myself. But now you give me no choice. He yanked her up, pressing his body to hers and forcing her face-to-face with him. She could see his pores. He held her like that for a moment. Then, seeing the men with the flyers across the street, he let go.
“我不想伤害你，”他说，声音哽咽。“我试着独自承受这一切。但现在你没给我选择。”他猛地把她拉起来，把身体贴向她，强迫她面对面。她能看到他的毛孔。他那样抓了她一会儿。然后，看到街对面有带传单的人，他放手了。
Hit me and I'll kill you mother [BLEEP]. Lupe tried to step away, readying her hands martial arts style for him.
“打我，我就杀了你，妈[哔]。”卢佩试图走开，准备好武术架势对付他。
Hey, she yelled in English to the two men across the street. This guy's trying to kill me. Can you call the cops?
“嘿，”她用英语对街对面的两个人喊道。“这人想杀我。你们能叫警察吗？”
The two looked at each other warily, then back across the street to Lupe in her battle stance. Raul was crying.
两人谨慎地看着对方，然后看向街对面摆出战斗姿态的卢佩。劳尔在哭。
The things you accuse me of, they're all things that you do, he said, wiping his eyes with the back of his fists. Well, I finally went and did one of them. It hurt me to do it. But I'm a man. I couldn't put up with this any longer.
“你指责我的事情，都是你自己做的事情，”他说，用拳头背擦着眼睛。“好吧，我终于去做了其中一件。做这件事让我很痛苦。但我是个男人。我再也忍受不了了。”
Hey, leave her alone, one of the men yelled from across the street. But it was lackluster. The second man walked slowly back to the diner where a blue metal flag advertised a public telephone inside.
“嘿，别管她，”其中一个人从街对面喊道。但这很无力。第二个人慢慢走回餐厅，里面有一面蓝色金属旗帜广告着里面的公用电话。
Raul, I don't want you near me, do you understand, Lupe said, switching back to Spanish. I don't know what the [BLEEP] you're talking about. But I'll tell you this much. If you keep this up, I'll file a police report, and the government will figure out what we're doing. And you will be shipped back. Do you understand?
“劳尔，我不想让你靠近我，你明白吗，”卢佩说，切回西班牙语。“我不知道你在说什么[哔]。但我会告诉你这么多。如果你继续这样，我会报警，政府会查清我们在做什么。你会被遣送回去。你明白吗？”
He didn't react to what she said. Instead, he took a deep breath and looked up at the sky.
他没对她的话做出反应。相反，他深吸了一口气，抬头看向天空。
I did it, you know, he finally said.
“我做了，你知道，”他终于说。
Did what, she asked, confused.
“做了什么，”她问，感到困惑。
I cheated on you, he said. She stared at him, her fighting posture loosened as she struggled for comprehension.
“我背叛了你，”他说。她盯着他，战斗姿态放松了，努力理解他的话。
I was with another woman, he said. Since you wouldn't act like a wife, I just couldn't take it anymore. And I had an affair behind your back.
“我和另一个女人在一起，”他说。“既然你不像个妻子那样行事，我就受不了了。我在你背后有了外遇。”
Lupe wanted to laugh, but didn't. She was stunned by the hopeless sincerity of his unnecessary confession.
卢佩想笑，但没笑。他那不必要的忏悔中绝望的诚意令她震惊。
I think that's good, Raul, she finally said. I think it's good that you get out and get involved. After all, we're not really married. We're only legally married. She smiled a little as she talked, trying desperately to be supportive.
“我觉得那很好，劳尔，”她最后说。“我觉得你走出去并参与其中是好事。毕竟，我们并不是真正的夫妻。我们只是法律上的夫妻。”她说话时露出一点微笑，极力试图表现出支持。
Raul closed his eyes, tears escaping from under the lids.
劳尔闭上眼睛，眼泪从眼皮下流出。
Oh, you are a cold, cold woman, he cried, his voice cracking again as he threw his hands in the air. Why did I have to marry such a cold woman?
“哦，你是个冷血的女人，”他哭道，声音再次哽咽，双手举向天空。“我为什么要娶一个这么冷的女人？”
Raul, you didn't marry a cold woman. You married a lesbian. He covered his ears with the palms of his hands. I don't want to hear that, he shouted. No, no, no. Lupe sighed and shook her head.
“劳尔，你没娶一个冷血女人。你娶了个女同性恋。”他用手掌捂住耳朵，“我不想听那个，”他喊道。“不，不，不。”卢佩叹了口气，摇了摇头。
God, this is absolutely not worth it, she said, more to herself than to him. The cops are on their way, said the man who'd gone back to the diner. He strolled back across the street to his partner, who had been serving as witness to Raul and Lupe's argument.
“天哪，这完全不值得，”她说，与其说是对他说的，不如说是对自己说的。“警察在路上了，”那个回到餐厅的人说。他慢慢走回街对面，回到他的同伴身边，同伴一直在见证劳尔和卢佩的争吵。
Raul, she said, her voice softer now, if the cops get here and we're still fighting, you'll probably be in trouble. So let's just go our separate ways, OK?
“劳尔，”她说，声音现在柔和了一些，“如果警察来了，我们还在争吵，你可能会有麻烦。所以我们各走各的路，好吗？”
"Don't you care?" he pleaded.
“你不关心吗？”他恳求道。
Yeah, I care, she said. That's why I'm telling you this. Please, go back to the restaurant. I'll just leave. And when the cops get here there won't be anybody to file charges.
“是的，我关心，”她说。“这就是为什么我告诉你这个。请，回到餐厅去。我会离开。警察来了就不会有人提出指控了。”
We're still married, he insisted. As if nothing else mattered. For just one more year, Raul. So don't blow it for yourself, she said. And please don't bother me anymore. You're trying my patience. Remember that I can put you right back on the wrong side of the river.
“我们还是夫妻，”他坚持道。好像其他任何事情都不重要。“就再等一年，劳尔。所以别把它搞砸了，”她说。“请别再打扰我了。你在考验我的耐心。记住，我可以把你重新放回河的另一边。”
They fell silent again.
他们再次沉默了。
What's that, he asked, nodding at her wrist.
“那是什么，”他问，点头示意她的手腕。
An ax, she said. He smiled a little, but he had already given up.
“一把斧头，”她说。他微微一笑，但他已经放弃了。
To cut off men's balls, I suppose.
“我想是为了割掉男人的蛋蛋。”
Yeah, she said. If necessary. They both laughed lightly, a little embarrassed. Raul shoved his hands in his pockets.
“是的，”她说。“如果有必要。”他们都轻声笑了起来，有些尴尬。劳尔把手插进兜里。
I hear you bought a house with Kate. With my money, he said, not meeting her eyes. She nodded. It was my money. I earned it. He looked up, but she refused to make eye contact.
“我听说你和凯特买了房子。用我的钱，”他说，不敢看她的眼睛。她点点头。“那是我的钱。我挣的。”他抬起头，但她拒绝目光接触。
You should get back to work, she said flatly. The cops will be here any moment, and I have to go.
“你该回去工作了，”她干巴巴地说。“警察随时会到，我得走了。”
Will you come by, see my mother, or maybe just call sometime, he asked.
“你会过来看看我母亲，或者只是打个电话吗，”他问。
You never give up, do you?
“你永远不会放弃，对吗？”
No.
“不。”
Well you should, Lupe said, then walked away. Her sharp strides put her across the street in seconds. Raul watched as she talked to the two men. After a moment, the men turned and left. Raul turned too, then quietly wandered back to the diner. By the time the squad car arrived at the corner, nobody was there.
“好吧，你应该放弃，”卢佩说，然后走开了。她敏捷的步伐让她在几秒钟内就穿过了街道。劳尔看着她和那两个人说话。片刻之后，那两个人转身离开了。劳尔也转身，然后静静地溜回了餐厅。当警车到达拐角处时，那里已经没有人了。
Achy Obejas is a cultural critic for the Chicago Tribune , that anti-slavery rag. This story is from her collection of short fiction, We Came All the Way from Cuba, So You Could Dress Like This?
阿奇·奥贝亚斯是《芝加哥论坛报》的文化评论员，就是那份反奴隶制小报。这个故事来自她的短篇小说集《我们从古巴一路走来，所以你可以打扮成这样？》。
Our program produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann and Sylvia Lemus.
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃维尔。豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like to buy a cassette copy of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380.
如果你想购买本节目的磁带副本，请致电我们芝加哥WBEZ，312-832-3380。
Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, where there are also photos of a teddy bear sitting on the four corners monument this week, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site.
或者你知道你可以在我们的网站上免费收听我们的大部分节目，网站上还有本周四角落纪念碑上坐着泰迪熊的照片，www.thislife.org。感谢负责网站运营的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes our program this way, where--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他这样描述我们的节目，哪里——
Booking guests whose near constant profanity makes the show into an unintelligible barrage of bleeps.
预订那些几乎不断使用亵渎语言的嘉宾，使节目变成一连串难以理解的哔哔声。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。